I I'm not obligated to and I leave I
can't afford to guess what
doesn't matter
you can't just so
just so you've had over a month
look you have done nothing but dig your
heels in and try and make me feel bad
about you
I am educate you no your education is
brainwashing
no it's me not going to listen to this
crap now
I don't care what you have
I don't it doesn't mean we live in
squalor and it doesn't mean you're a
bully you I'm not even a bully you
literally detonate me misgender me and
tell me that apparently it's not clear
to people that I am mentally and
physically disabled
I can't just go out and get a [ __ ]
job apparently I have to remind people
that we're in the middle of the people
have been asking updates and I'm going
to update and also clear some things up
apparently it's not clear to people that
I am mentally and physically disabled if
you're in the age of
being able to live alone
and you live with your parents and you
nagged them and you nag them and you nag
them
it's a possibility that eventually
they will kick you out
that being said
it's not because you are mentally ill it
excuses you from everything it doesn't
your illness is not an excuse for
everything I cannot be a jackass to this
man and after that claim it on hey you
know what I'm mentally ill
at some point I'm gonna have to do
something about it
um some point I'm gonna have to do
something about it and
not to be a problem to people or not to
be a burden to people understand what
I'm saying
third thing that I'm gonna say the mom
said oh you're not allowed to be a bully
and everything and stuff and stuff like
that that's what I've been founding
every Community that's been ostracized
being they eventually become a bully
they eventually become a bully we could
name the community it's going to be that
whether it's uh women with feminism at
first needed then become a bully whether
it's become the community
first needed then you become a bully
that's why your mama kicked your ass out
on the point of this topic
okay I'm gonna give you the spicy tape
this is the spicy thing go ahead I don't
even think she got schizophrenia listen
I'm relaxed with you just listening to
her talk and her going through that
whole thing I think some people just
love the whole mental health label I
didn't want to go there
go there yeah I don't give a coin yeah
New Year you'll be attacking me [ __ ]
[Music]
you I don't care bash you I think people
like all kinds of layers I've seen
people [ __ ] claim the autism things
with zero diagnosis because it's cool to
be autistic bro okay listen I'm not
joking there is something very bizarre
where people wanting to claim illnesses
and issues that they don't have it's
been it's like the Rachel dolez-off
thing yes you need to be like yeah that
thing yeah forget transracial trans
diagnosis yes
it's been going like that for years
remember I remember when I was she said
you dead name to be you misgendered me
you won't acknowledge like oh my gosh
like how many layers of pressure you got
on this household really I I'm just
saying I I could be wrong no couldn't
come out there I don't think you are but
you know just hearing her talk and be
like I don't think people realize this
but I have mental health like oh no this
is somebody just didn't smell right I
was like oh you can't find a job you
probably can't with those piercings in
your nose
you probably can't with that hair color
in that unscruffed look
listen
she just looks like a giant brat who
doesn't want to assume responsibilities
and is trying to be interesting by
looking crazy that's what it appears on
the outside looking in for the parent
who's being patient it's like yo listen
you of age it's time for you to be an
adult she didn't want to cry she said
pay your part of the rent
pay your part of the rent I don't think
that's an unreasonable thing to ask
I don't think that's under and she's
saying that you know that why that
probably is
it's probably because this kid's not
going to school they're not doing much
with their life they don't have a job
either so it's just like you're being a
[ __ ] deadbeat and you're hiding
behind this mental illness and this kind
of bullying to try to emotionally
manipulate me to doing what you want
that's what it appears like on the
outside now there's a lot of details
that can make me change my mind okay but
just using the few words that the mom
views and also what's interesting is the
girl filmed it and put this online you
know how delusional you have to be to
put that [ __ ] up and think you're going
to be the one who's gonna get sympathy
girl
you filmed that interaction with your
mom not with your mom if your mom would
have put up that video I would have felt
different
but it was you who decided to film that
interaction and upload it that's you
trying to Garner sympathy from people
and manipulating that's you I'm the same
what's the date in priest's life look
like I wake up in the morning like
everybody else then well I take care of
my wife's [ __ ] yeah I pet it I mean you
know everybody knows my wife's [ __ ]
then I head downstairs to uh to train I
train a bit do my little boxing then
after that I wash myself and after that
I dress up and I put on some perfume
there's one thing about looking good but
smelling good there's a whole difference
in order to to do that you have to find
the right combination and sometimes the
perfume they're expensive I'm a perfume
Aficionado I got a lot of perfume in my
cupboard but to get to that I gotta try
on a lot of them and to do that well it
costs a lot of money but I got the thing
for you set Berg yeah look at this they
send you samples like a month supply
usually a supply of perfume we talk
about it simple it looks like this is
look at that well let me take that out
and show you
for a fraction of the price of the real
perfume yeah and then you can be you're
able to test different perfume like you
see here in the package that I receive I
receive Wildfire by Ross period I
received stag by the maker and I already
see some Dolce and Gabbana Light Blue
and tons yeah
wow
wow
foreign
I have some thoughts on this as I
mentally and physically disabled person
this person uploaded a video screaming
at their parent because they wanted four
weeks notice when they are not obligated
to get that because they are not paying
rent to live there they use the excuse
of being mentally insulated able to not
be able to get a job
let's talk about that I myself and
physically and mentally disabled
I've gotten four jobs during the pen
and before anyone says it's kind of live
in a big city I got two of those jobs in
a very tiny City with under 3 000 people
yes disabilities can be debilitating and
that's what they are disabilities which
sometimes mean you can't always work and
that's fine but from what she said I
know personally tons of people that work
with the disabilities that they have
using disabilities to be completely rude
to random people or your parents or
family is not okay it's definitely not
okay to use your disability as an excuse
to not pay rent wherever you're living
it's been going on for ages because I
remember when I was in elementary school
there's some people that faked
having a eye problem because they wanted
to have classes because the glasses were
cool you know it's been going since then
then after that when after after it was
glasses it was glasses then after that
it was uh contacts right after contact
it would before contact sorry before
contacts was braces some people were
getting braces you wanted to get braces
some people that you know just wanted
braces because they like the attention
there's some people always like whenever
I at that when we hit high school and it
was like this store that you could buy
some stuff they would buy the bandages
like oh I hurt myself just just to look
like they hurt yourself because they
like the attention oh what happened to
some people really just want to be asked
oh my God
[Music]
what happened what happened to it they
just ask that like Hi how are you how
was your day is not enough for some
[ __ ] and they want to re-up on
stuff and now a couple of Ages back
years years back was add now
[ __ ] are on the Spectrum you
know I mean they're Asperger we can't
say that no more they're on the Spectrum
and now it's all this rest and [ __ ] so
yes I think you are absolutely right
it's been it's not new it's been going
on for ages and every every five years
and some new [ __ ] you said they're on
the Spectrum and I kept thinking like
yes yes asparagus
listen
[Music]
when I say power meters I acknowledge
the fact that I say that [ __ ] raw you
don't give a [ __ ] I guess Asperger
sounds fire okay we want Aspergers
together
[Music]
to get Asperger
if you have a child who has autism or
some severe mental disability generally
speaking the state has programs in place
to give you money that's why I also
don't believe this girl and what she's
saying my mom probably don't believe
that [ __ ] yeah give me my check stupid
we got no mental nothing okay okay so
that's that's all about my house but
let's say
okay you are telling the truth you are
your trades and all these things and
she's misgendering you and all this
other stuff
this is gonna be the [ __ ] up part
your parent in an ideal world is very
supportive and wants to be by your side
and help you but sometimes they don't
and once you're a grown-ass person you
gotta have to realize like that might
not be the place you want to be at
you trying to sit there and be like if
she's like some kind of fundamental
Christian she don't believe in anything
more than two genders and whatever else
hey it's her home if you don't like that
you can't just spend that whole time
trying to change her mind
right my mom want to run a Muslim
household all the power to her I bounced
I had to real quick yes [ __ ] you can't
big back Sandra when is Haram you know
what I'm saying
Cassandra went by and put on no [ __ ]
hey job you get what I'm trying it is
what it is you gotta book it
that's your you want to do it your way
you want to live with your life with
your values and your ideas and your
identity that's fine
not under her roof it's like you want to
not be religious that's okay not under
her roof that's the way it works when
you're a child they have a
responsibility towards you while you're
dependent and you have to be after that
point passes you got to understand if
you want to have independent thought you
want to have an independent identity and
do whatever you want thereby no means
obligated to keep you in their home
that's why I always tell people you
don't gotta say if they want to give you
one yes but they don't have to wonder
why they pay the bills
the re the moment I had a choice and
what happens in my mom's household or
any household is when I paid the bills
and now my mom got a consult me
because I paid this stuff
she want to come in here with that
Muslim sounds like it's Haram today okay
now don't do that I'll do that I let my
mom pray she can do whatever she wants
you know you just can't get mad you just
can't get mad at me if I don't think
it's just a different [ __ ] like listen
mama I bring pork every now and then but
I hide it we do things yeah but you're
respectful enough to hide it so good on
you yeah but when I cook the bacon I
make it extra loud to give you the
sizzling
add extra oil yeah yeah he deep fries
because we can't use the same package
but you know I didn't hear what I didn't
understand what you said but I
understood what you said yeah there's a
different pan
it's fine it's fine but listen it is
what it is you know I mean like you're
not paying the bills okay you're paying
none of it there you go
her house get the [ __ ] out of here you
know I mean I bet you are a lonely child
the [ __ ] out of here I'm just saying
I'll be honest with you I think she's
faking most of it that's just I've got
the same sentence that's what you guys
think in the comments